chào các bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn
chúng
ta thao tác để tạo cái công thức toán
học trong Microsoft Word
và chúng ta bắt đầu à chúng ta vào thẻ
Insert trong cung symbol chúng ta chọn
là
equation Và sẽ xuất hiện cái hội Tho cái
ô là ty equation here có nghĩa là gõ
công thức ở đây và nguyên tắc là những
ký tự nào có trên bần phím thì chúng ta
gõ còn ký từ nào mà không có trên bàn
phím thì chúng ta phải chèn từ cái phần
symbol ở trong cái thẻ equation thì thứ
nhất là s bằ là có trên bằng phím chúng
ta gõ vào tiếp theo là căn thức căn thức
thì chúng ta sẽ
chọn chúng ta mở rộng cửa sổ guột ra
chúng ta xem chúng ta chọn căn ở
đây và sau đó chúng ta chọn
tiếp
căn à trong căn thì sẽ có đối tượng là
ngoặc rồi phân số và lưu ý chúng ta là
nguyên tắc tạo công thức là từ ngoài vào
trong ví dụ như chúng ta thấy là s bằng
sau đó căn là ngoài cùng trong căn thì
có gì cặp ngoặc rồi A + B + C tr2 như
vậy chúng ta sẽ tạo ngoặc trước r tạo
phân số sau như vậy ngoặc thì chúng ta
sẽ vào mục ở đây
ngoặc
chọn tiếp chúng ta nhấp vào hình vuông
trong ngoặc chúng ta chọn phân số chúng
ta nhấp vào một phân số ở đây và chọn
phân số sau đó chúng ta đặt trọ ở tử
chúng ta gõ vào a c b và cộng c chúng ta
gõ vào tiếp tục chúng ta sẽ gõ vào công
số 2 ở mẫu số bây giờ tiếp tục chúng ta
sẽ tạo ra cái ngoặc thứ hai ngoặc thứ
hai thì chúng ta sẽ dùng phím mũi tên
qua phải hoặc là nhắp
chuột ngoài cái dòng ngoặc này Đấy và
lưu ý rằng khi nhắp chuột ngoài dòng
ngặc ngặc thì trong ngoặc nó được tô
xám lúc này chúng ta tạo ra một đối
tượng thì đối tượng đó nó nằm cùng cấp
với cái đối tượng được tô xám đây có
nghĩa là nó nằm trong căn Còn nếu chúng
ta nhắp mà cái đối tượng trong căn không
được tô
xám như ở trên màn hình đây thì khi
chúng ta tạo ra một đối tượng Đối tượng
đó nó nằm ngoài căn ví dụ chúng ta tạo
ra ngoặc này chúng ta quan sát chúng ta
xem cái ngoặc này nó nằm ngoài căn mất
rồi này nó sai so với bài đấy Vậy thì
chúng ta xóa nó đi chúng ta nhắp chuột
sao cho sát n dụ ngoặc sao cho là toàn
bộ trong
ngoặc toàn bộ bộ trong căn nó được tốt
xám Lúc đó chúng ta tạo ra đối tượng thì
đối tượng đó mới nằm trong căn Và bây
giờ chúng ta tạo
ngoặc đấy và sau đó chọn à hình vuông
trong ngoặc chúng ta chọn phân
số chúng ta gõ tử số cũng là a + b và
cộng c và phân số là mẫu số là 2 sau đó
chúng ta đặt cung trọ trước dấu ngoặc
đng sau
cho sao cho A + B + C tr2 là được tô xảm
thì chúng ta mới gọ dấu trừ và gõ số chữ
A vào tiếp tục chúng ta nhắp vào ngoài
ngoặc lúc này toàn bộ trong căn được tô
xám thì chúng ta tiếp tục kèn ngoặc vào
thì ngoặc này nó mới nằm trong căn và
tương tự như thế chúng ta tạo phân số
chúng ta gõ tử số a + b + c và mẫu số
chúng ta gõ con số 2 tiếp tục đặt C trỏ
trước dấu ngoặc
đng sao cho phân số đó được tô xám thì
lúc đó chúng ta mới gõ
trừ
B và lại tiếp tục nhắp trỏ vào ngoài dấu
ngoặc toàn bộ trong căn sô nền xám thì
chúng ta mới ới tạo cái ngoặc thứ hai
nếu không tô nền xám như thế này nhắc
lại nếu không tô nền xám thì chúng ta
tạo ra đối tượng Đối tượng đó nằm ngoài
căn à lưu ý cái
đó chúng ta nhấp sao cho nhắp chuột sát
n dụ ngoặc sao cho toàn bộ trong căn
được tô xám thì chúng ta mới tiếp
tục và chúng ta cũng chèn thân số vào và
chúng ta gõ tử số a c+ b + c và dưới mẫu
số chúng ta gõ 2 và chúng ta gõ vào
tiếp trừ
c kết thúc công thức chúng ta nhắp chuột
vào một vị trí trống trên màn hình để
kết thúc đây chúng ta có được công thức
toàn học tiếp tục chúng ta làm nghiệm
phương trình bậc 2 thì chúng ta cũng vào
tiếp là Insert symbol
equation và chúng ta sẽ chọn người ngoặc
ngoài cùng ra trước ngoặc vuông ra trước
này nhắc lại nguyên tắc
là từ ngoài vào trong khi tạo công thức
cho nên chúng ta phải chọn ngoặc trước
đây ngoặc vuông ngoặc vuông này nhắp sau
đó là hai dòng thì chúng ta sẽ chọn cái
ma trận chúng ta nhắp chuột vào matx đây
ma Trần đây chúng ta chọn hai
dòng sau khi chọn hai dòng xong thì thì
chúng ta tiếp tục đặt trỏ vào hình vuông
ở dòng thứ nhất Chúng ta chọn X1 X1 là
chỉ số dưới thì chúng ta sẽ chọn f mũ x
đây và chúng ta chọn dạng chỉ số dưới
đây nhấp subscript nhá và hình vuông lớn
chúng ta gõ chữ X hình vuông nhỏ chúng
ta gõ con số
1 sau khi gõ X và 1 xong chúng ta khoan
gõ dấu bằng mà chúng ta dùng phím mũi
tên qua phải để toàn bộ X1 tô sá thì lúc
đó mới X1 bằng Còn nếu chúng ta mà không
không tô xám X1 thì có nghĩa là 1 bằng
chứ không phải X1 bằng như vậy nhắc lại
là chúng ta dùng phím mũi tên qua phải
nha Bằng và chúng ta tiếp là chọn phân
số phân số chúng ta chọn đây và tử số
chúng ta sẽ gõ vào là - B sau đó cộng
căn Delta căn thì chúng ta chọn căn căn
thức căn thức đâ đ đây căn thức và Delta
là không có trên bàn phím cho nên chúng
ta tìm và mục symbol
đây chúng ta tìm đến Delta và tiếp tục
là mẫu số chúng ta gõ vào là
[âm nhạc]
2a tương tự như thế cái hình vuông Thứ
hai chúng ta cũng chọn chỉ số
dưới subscript
và hình vuông lớn chúng ta gõ chữ X hình
vuông nhỏ chúng ta gõ con số 2 chúng ta
nhắp chuột vào nha Rồi sau đó nếu chúng
ta để y như này chúng ta gõ bằng có
nghĩa là 2 bằng nha chứ không phải X2 bằ
lưu ý cái đó Bây giờ chúng ta muốn là X2
bằ thì nhớ là nhấn phím mũi tên qua
phải toàn bộ X2 được tô Sám thì lúc đó
mới có nghĩa là X2 bằng và chúng ta gõ
dấu bằng vào và chúng ta chọn phân số và
chúng ta gõ vào tử số là trừ Ừ
B trừ căn Delta chúng ta chọn
căn và tiếp tục chúng ta Điền Delta vào
và tiếp tục là
2a đây và như vậy công thức nghiệm
phương trình bậc hai kết thúc và cách
làm như
vậy cái phần Chèn công thức toán học này
nè ch T có hai lưu ý lưu ý thứ nhất là
khi tạo công thức là tạo từ ngoài vào
trong Tức cái Tức là cái nào ngoài á thì
mình tạo ví dụ đây là căn thức ngoài
cùng chúng ta tạo trước ví dụ ngoặc
ngoài chúng ta tạo trước tạo dụ ngoặc
xong mới tạo phân số
đấy đó là nguyên cái thứ nhất cái thứ
hai lưu ý là khi chúng ta tạo ra một đối
tượng thì đối tượng đó là nó cung cấp
với đối tượng nào Ví dụ như ở đây
Nếu có bổ sung thêm thì chúng ta đặt trõ
ngoài dống ngoặc này nè toàn bộ trong
căn nó được tô xám thì đối tượng tiếp
theo nó sẽ cùng cấp có nghĩa là nó nằm
trong căn Còn nếu mà nó không tô xám ví
dụ dùng phím mối tên qua phải nó mất tô
xám rồi thì lúc đó chúng ta chèn một đối
tượng vào đối tượng đó nó sẽ nằm ngoài
căn Tức là không cùng cấp ví dụ đây gõ a
c d các bạn quan sát thấy nó nằm ngoài
căn chưa đấy như vậy khi lập công thức
toán học chúng ta lưu ý hai nội dung đó
nha Rồi đến đây bài về tạo công thức
toàn học kết thúc Xin chào các bạn